well bus ridership is down during the
pandemic that's not surprising news
but proposing some cuts to make up
revenue
and patch up a 63 million dollar budget
hole
hector mejia is live in the southwest
valley with what this could mean for
passengers good morning to you hector
hey there alex good morning and rtc
started operating their schedule on a
cut back schedule the saturday schedule
every day of the week and
if you haven't been on a bus lately
you'll notice once you board the bus
you'll say hi to the bus driver sexy
glass shield
and that not everything is available
some are blocked off to allow for more
social distancing and the signage inside
for that six feet of distance is pretty
obvious and rtc is now thinking about
making more
changes it's proposing cutting four bus
routes and making other adjustments
including schedule changes
the specific routes that could be
impacted are on rtc's website
the agency is holding a virtual public
meeting this afternoon from 1 30 to 3 30
they want to hear from their passengers
that's because rtc is facing a 63
million dollar budget shortfall
and they tell us it was much higher than
that at one point
with covid it was a 102 million dollars
deficit we've actually proceeded to
internal cuts
where we were able to save 40 million
but we're still facing a 63 million
dollar
financial burden
covert 19 is changing the face of
transportation within the next six
months
rtc plans to install technology designed
to neutralize viruses
and germs not only in the air but also
on surfaces that again
that uh technology they're hoping to
implement that in new buses within the
next six months or so
and they are seeking input again from
their passengers by august 28th
on the proposals they have on the table
to cut some service
as they try to deal with a 63 million
dollar budget deficit
reporting live in the southwest hector
mejia 8 news now